hi I'm Eric Voss and this pre Avengers
in game time is getting pretty hard to
fill with anything other than hiding in
a bunker with no Wi-Fi to avoid all the
leaks and spoilers but I think the best
way to prep is a wide-eyed in-depth
rewatch of Avengers infinity war because
pretty much every frame of this movie is
filled with details many of which we
overlooked the first time have you
haven't already you should watch my
first breakdown for all the references
to the comics and other interesting
details but here I'm gonna go even
deeper and explain how infinity war is a
real different movie than what we
remember it was spoiler warning in case
they accidentally predict something that
happens in Avengers in game but you know
what no spoiler warning for infinity war
you have had a year okay infinity war
opens with the foreboding distress call
from the Asgardian refugee ship that we
saw at the end of Thor Ragnarok
and the reason this distress call sounds
so distressed is that this is a voice of
Kenneth Branagh Shakespearean trade
actor and director of the first Thor
movie this edita had brought it before
but free watching this movie center
stain of this movie book ends with
another distress call from another
director director Nick Fury with him
getting the line perfectly suited for
the actor mother working on the ship
Eponine mom thanassis Black Order steps
over the bodies of the Asgardians but is
actually confirmed after this release
that some of the Asgardians did escape
this Massacre including Valkyrie then we
meet the central character of infinity
war Thanos the writers and the directors
have said that the only way to structure
a story with over twenty characters was
to make the villain the real protagonist
now that doesn't make famous the hero
looking at you Thanos did nothing wrong
groupies it just means that he is a
character with the most clearly defined
goal Josh Brolin based his performance
on Marlon Brando's Colonel Kurtz
character from Apocalypse Now who is
another iconic bald war monger too
hungry for genocide at 29 minutes Thanos
is the most screen time and infinity war
followed by Gamora at 19 and a half Tony
Stark at 18 Doctor Strange at 12
millions of years technically speaking
and Thor at 14 and a half minutes so
Thor has exactly half the amount of
screen time that Thanos did and here
he's about half his size you actually
don't even initially notice that the
limp rag doll at Thanos his feet is the
god of thunder by opening this film with
these two zeroes infinitive or
establishes Santos's and Thor's opposing
arcs as the most critical and if we
consider panis to be the protagonist
that would make for the story's
antagonist now to be clear Thor and the
rest of the Avengers are definitely the
good guys here but throughout this
rewatch I'm gonna point out some
evidence to make the case that Thor is
the structural villain of this story I
mean he does only have one eye here guys
Thanos reveals his Infinity Gauntlet
closing his fist to power up the power
stone and throughout this movie notice
that Thanos can only use the stones when
his fist is clenched it's a key detail
when they tried to physically overpower
him later
Thanos gaining the Power Stone from
Xander was actually removed from an
early draft of the script however there
was
some speculation from the in-game
trailer footage that the second movie
would show us the ruins of Xan dark Loki
presents the tesseract containing the
space stone which he grabbed from Odin's
vault before Asgard was destroyed and
Ragnarok the timeline of the story
immediately after Ragnarok suggests that
it was actually Asgard's destruction and
the death of Odin as protector of the
nine realms that opened the door for
Thanos to finally make his move when my
favorite theories is that Thanos could
actually have been following in Odin's
footsteps with Odin possibly having
similarly attempted his own infinity
conquest and paid a costly price for it
but more on that later loki tells Thanos
we have a home a call back to Tony
Stark's words to Loki in the first
Avengers movie and at least it is big
brawl between the crayola meatheads
Thanos actually doesn't use the Power
Stone during this fight a subtle way of
establishing his ferocity as a Genghis
Khan's style Conqueror who don't need no
magic their fight plays out like a
boxing match with Hulk winning round one
initially overpowering Thanos and Hulk
smashing him into a wall squeezing out a
grumpy grunt from grimace but dinging
round to Thanos realizes he has sharper
wits than this dumb-dumb and he knocks
out Hoke's airflow with a jab to the
throat and then windows ribs leading to
a KO now sure it's not totally comic
accurate for a hoax who ever lose a
fight like he's supposed to just grow
bigger and angrier some have even used
this as grounds for conspiracy saying
that this could actually be Loki
masquerading as Hulk with Loki faking
his death and disguising himself as
Bruce Banner for the rest of the movie
people also pointed to some debris
floating outside when Loki actually gets
his neck snapped some debris that looks
like the real Loki wearing his helmet
and others have pointed out that it's
weird that Bruce Banner remembers
memories from when Hulk was in control
instead of blacking out like he has in
the past well I'll actually give you
that one but really I think the
filmmakers wanted Hulk's performance
anxiety to be the next step of the
characters evolution across the MCU
films to this point from an animalistic
rage monster to a lonely Frankenstein's
monster to a cocky gladiator and now to
a more emotional entity with a more
nuanced relationship with Bruce Banner
as ebony maw presents Thanos the space
stone he says my
personnage vows before your friend
humble person yes somebody wants a raise
Maz goofy line here is actually a direct
quote from the character met disto in
the Infinity Gauntlet comics title page
of the black order members ebony ma has
the most defined personality despite
that in the recent Marvel comics all of
them get more background for example
Corvus glaive and Proxima midnight
actually married
much chemistry though they're going
through a lot and Co obsidians most
specific trait is that a flashy sash
that bangs around his waist many people
actually thought that looked like
Captain Marvel's color scheme but it's
actually orange and purple signifying
nothing
well Maas characters a bit more fun to
watch his character is a mix of Mephisto
as Thanos is devious right-hand man from
the comics with just a splash of that a
nerdy Nazi and Raiders of the Lost Ark
as Thanos takes a space stone he removes
his helmet and his armor despite a few
more fights ahead of him for the nose
the hard part is over the remaining
steps of this stone quest is more of a
spiritual journey for him and from this
point forward dannis never diverts from
his goal to give in to his more violent
tendencies actually fulfills all of his
promises he spares Thor in exchange for
the space stone he spares nebula in
exchange for Gamora telling him where
the soul stone was and he spares Tony
Stark in exchange for the time stone
he's still a murderous piece of crap but
he definitely keeps his word meanwhile
Thor's journey here can be seen as a
classic villain Origen grieving over his
dead brother swearing selfish vengeance
kind of like Jeremy Irons a die hard
with a vengeance
swearing death to non purple Bruce
Willis to avenge his dead brother Hans
Gruber I mean Sam Jackson wasn't both
movies okay I know all of that was just
for the opening sequence but don't worry
I'm gonna move fast through the rest of
this like I know Bruce Banner crashed
land in the sanctum sanctorum was a nod
to Silver Surfer doing it in the comics
but I already covered that in my first
breakdown so if I skip over a future
comic references throughout this I
didn't miss it I just covered in another
video ok Tony Stark and Pepper Potts jog
in the park with Tony talking about a
did the dream he had about them having a
kid named Morgan his confusion of dreams
and reality should remind us of his
nightmare vision back in age of Ultron
the dream that launched his paranoia
over Thanos leading him to
I to weaponize an infinity stone when he
probably should have just sought to
destroy it actually later while being
debriefed in the sanctum Stark nods and
says it's a subtle callback to the
moment and Ultron when he first spoke
what would eventually be the title of
the final film with Avengers we can bust
arms dealers all the live long day but
that up there that's that's the end game
now when stark and strange start talking
about the time stone things get really
interesting and this still may be the
best chance we have against them is so
converse they may also be his best
chance against us so if we don't do our
jobs what is your job exactly besides
making balloon animals
protecting your reality douchebag
Kian nerd burn so in this moment it
sounds like Doc Strange is already
brainstorming strategies for how to use
the time stone against Thanos later in
the movie Strange uses the time stone to
look into future timelines but we have
speculated many other possible secret
uses like putting everyone inside a time
loop that will reset and give them
infinite shots and find in a victory
path and by saying protecting your
reality douchebag strange is calling
Tony Stark a douchebag it's also
acknowledging a vast multiverse of
parallel realities
perhaps hinting at another way to defeat
Thanos splitting into alternate
timelines and actually after this movie
came out ant-man the wasp also shed
light on the existence of multiple
parallel realities through the quantum
realm in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Peter Parker sees the calamity from his
school bus the hairs on his arm shoot up
a representation of Peters spidey sense
something that we didn't really see him
used in spider-man homecoming but he
does have it because he definitely used
it in an airport battle in the Civil War
later Peter tells Stark that he came
from a field trip and to be clear that
field trip is not the euro trip from
spider-man far from home that movie is a
sequel not a secret prequel set before
Infinity Ward Stark shows off his new
nanotech armor based on his bleeding
edge armor from the comics Stark takes
off his Friday linked sunglasses as the
armor flows over his body and the
sunglasses just get absorbed into the
armor on his fingers so really Stark
just took off his sunglasses as a kind
of intimidation tactic the guardians of
the galaxy respond to the Kenneth
Branagh distress call and James Gunn
Clair
by that the ship they're on here is
called the Benatar since the Milano was
destroyed and Guardians volume to Thor's
arrival here once again paints him in a
sort of villainous light he frightens
them by slamming into their ship and
they'll scream again when his eye pops
open and then once inside the ship he
goes around ranting about getting a new
powerful weapon to go kill someone I
mean if we didn't know well maybe kind
of like running into Michael Myers with
your RV and then freaking out when
Michael starts looking for a bigger
knife to go kill Laurie Strode he'd be
like dude chill it's also interesting to
rewatch rocket in this moment because
notice how he joins Thorne it of Lear
instead of joining the other guardians
to go confront vanos directly and then
as you watch this movie rocket is the
one major hero not to make direct
contact with Thanos all the rest take
swings that Thanos either on Titan or in
that final charge on Wakanda but rocket
nowhere to be seen perhaps Rockets
avoidance tells us something about its
relationship with Bannos like we never
really knew the secret origin of rockets
cybernetic enhancements and one theory
is that it could be a runaway child of
Thanos that's why he was kind of hiding
from famous throughout this movie vision
and Wanda Maximoff stars of the upcoming
unfortunately titled Disney Plus series
1 division respond to a warning from the
mind stone
and we don't really see the mind stones
power manifest in any specific way in
this movie but we do know it has some
cosmic intelligence it gives people the
power of mind-control but it also has a
kind of a dark mind of its own there's
actually a theory that the mind stone
itself is behind all of this drama
playing a long game to gradually
manipulate the Avengers to turn on each
other
weaken them all from the inside and
expose them to a worthy force to reunite
it with the others of its kind one could
say the same thing about our genes using
our bodies as flesh puppets to replicate
themselves freewill is a myth nobody
exists on purpose nobody belongs
anywhere everybody's going to die come
watch TV Hampton America helps vision
and Wanda now bearded wearing a civil
war suit but it's d saturated with all
of its patriotic insignia torn off caps
big entrance here almost wasn't in the
movie he was originally going to make
his surprise appearance during the
Battle of Wakanda kind of like Thor's
big entrance but they move cap earlier
because even though endgame is a bigger
story for his character he couldn't be a
no-show in the first half an infinity
war a flashback reveals the decimation
of gomorrah's home race the Z homer by
Thanos the black order and its
and it's interesting to witness an
example of another alien race being
slaughtered by an attack that the
adventures on earth overcame showing how
awful our fate could have been and a
tease of the awful fate to come in an
early pre-release scene of the in-game
Captain Marvel snapped at rody that the
reason she didn't help the Avengers in
past battles is that she was busy
fighting to save other planets across
the galaxy just like this one the fact
that the Avengers defeated that j't re
then is an especially big deal
there was a long deadly warpath from
planet to planet and they put a stop to
it now infinity Wars to best pop culture
Easter eggs show up when the Guardians
sneak into the collectors vault and know
where Gamora passes a tank containing
this blue man Tobias few K from Arrested
Development the sitcom that the Russo
brothers used to work on they also snuck
in a Bluth company stair truck in the
background of the airport in Civil War
and the other one when Thanos
interrogate spenita del Toro as a
collector he asked he's actually doing
an exact impression of del Torres
character in the movie snatched the
jewel thief Franky four fingers famous
reveals he actually already has the
reality stone is all a projected reality
over the ruins of nowhere
even though fantasies is the reality
stone who turned Rex into blocks and
mantis and the ribbons and quills
blaster-bolt into bubbles why doesn't
use it more in later battles the
filmmakers made sure to show that us
using each stone at least once in the
scene after his acquisition of that
stone the way I played the crap out of
this toy infinity got with the first
night I got it and then I you know
scaled it down to like two hours a day
after that and Bannister's case he could
use the reality stone to toy with the
heroes or the movie like popped their
eyes out on springs or turn them inside
out or make their faces but but this
version of Thanos has his eyes on the
prize
he's not evil he's just all business and
that business is itself evil enough and
Avengers HQ Rhodey hollow chats with
secretary Ross and what Abraxas aides
it's actually a cameo by one of the
movie's screenwriters Stephen McFeely a
deleted scene from the park with happy
hogan actually glued a cameo by one of
the directors Joe Russo as Bert's the
paparazzo
Natacha mentions Clint Barton and Scott
Lang are under house arrest following
the events of civil war because they
both have families it's kind of hard for
them to go on the run and ant-man the
wasp Scott is revealed
you have an ankle bracelet monitor and
actually endgame scenes show Hawkeye
with a similar one the team debates
removing the mind stone from vision and
destroying it and visions willing to
sacrifice himself but cap responds we
don't trade lives vision this line
connects to the theme of sacrifice at
the heart of the story
these Avengers have proven they're
willing to sacrifice their own lives but
are they willing to sacrifice the lives
of others Bannos is stronger will to
follow through in this regard makes him
the champion of this particular test on
the cue ship stark and Peter save
strangers in an alien style suck him out
through the airlock move evany Maw
releases the subtlest Wilhelm scream
when he shoots out and after some debate
it strange makes a pretty dark assurance
to Stark if it comes to saving you or
the kid or the time stone
I'm not hesitate to let either of you
die yeah way to return the favor for
them saving your life doc strangest
words foreshadow the final sacrifice of
this movie and strangers eyes the end
game the final phase of the game of
chess in which all pieces on the board
from the pawns to your queen are on the
chopping block if it leads you to a
checkmate in a throne room of the
sanctuary to Thanos outlines his
philosophy to Kimora this universe is
finite its resources finite his life is
left unchecked life who ceased to exist
so in the comics Thanos was a lot more
two-dimensional literally he's on a page
but also the characters are super
over-the-top the only reason he wants to
kill half the life in the universe is
just to impress mistress death whom he's
in love with but in this movie
Dallas's worldview is a lot more complex
it actually comes from the Malthusian
ISM theory which proposes that
overpopulation is the primary source of
conflicts and poverty around the world
and that deadly natural disasters like
pandemics and tsunamis are ultimately
good for Humanity yeah I bet Malthus is
a real hit at parties Thanos gets a
location the soul stone out of Gomorrah
by torturing old waste departs herself
nebula and he uses both the space stone
and the power stone at the same time to
torture her I assume the space stone is
too spatially pull her parts apart from
each other and the power stone is to
keep it all bound together kind of
squeezing his daughter between two
gargantuan sources of pain by the way
double the pain he delivered to Thor's
temple with just a power stone I said it
once I'll say it again father
oh you ended of Alire Thor rocket and
Groot meet each tree Peter Dinklage
whose hands vanna's cut off leaving him
with these crude guru hands that he made
for himself
according to concept art the original
design was for a tree to have rounded
off Aroo stumps simper Groot to climb on
his back and extend his branches forming
a trees no hands to help him forge
Thor's new weapon actually even earlier
concept art showed Thor descending into
a giant cavern and finding Stormbreaker
nestled in a vine covered hole that
looked a lot like the corpse of a giant
creature maybe a dragon instead the
filmmakers wanted Thord have to work a
lot harder to gain this weapon comparing
his quest to the labors of Hercules the
twelve tasks that that mythological hero
had to complete as penance for his past
mistakes group does end up playing a
crucial role in the formation of
Stormbreaker providing one of his arms
as a handle and some of asked well since
Groot can regenerate from mere twigs of
himself after he faded in the snap
shouldn't he be able to regenerate from
the Stormbreaker handle or if not
shouldn't the handle dust away - it's a
good question but from what I can tell
from other examples of people who dust
thanassis snap seems to affect the parts
of you that are like part of your
identity in that moment so clothes
accessories Bucky's arm they all fade
with the person but not Fury's pager
which he had just picked up and not
groots arm which ceased to be part of
his identity the moment it became part
of something new a new magical weapon
Stormbreaker ain't and along the bladed
edge of Stormbreaker they're actually
some Asgardian runes that translate to
loose the dogs of war a popular phrase
that dates back to shakespeare's julius
caesar which includes the famous phrase
cry havoc and let slip the dogs of wool
on Vermeer dannis in gomorrah encounter
well what red skull
after a flu shane away from the
tesseract in Captain America the First
Avenger he's now a stone keeper to these
soul stones he greets Thanos as ours is
actually the name of Thanos's father and
eternal has been to suicide in son of
Chronos the eternal who became the
cosmic embodiment of time itself I know
comics maybe they're mentioning allows
here to get another way time could be
meddled with in the future of the MCU
Samus of course sacrifices Gomorrah
which reminds me of that will Odin
parallel I brought up earlier
what if Odin once faced this test as
well sacrificing his daughter hella we
know it's banished to another dimension
and came back when he died you could see
how Odin would have never forgiven
himself and then decided to scatter the
stones across the universe perhaps the
way Odin was haunted by his daughter so
too may Thanos by his on Titan the
Avengers meet the Guardians and Doctor
Strange looks ahead and time at fourteen
million six hundred five possible
futures saying they only win in one of
those timelines over the past year we
have speculated a lot over what the
exact conditions of Doctor Strange is
one victorious timeline plan could be be
sure to check out all the videos on the
subject especially the most recent one
about the
I'm Luke theory their battle with Thanos
features a number of subtle visual
details especially in the way the anise
uses interesting combinations of stones
like he uses the soul stone twice in
this sequence once in combination with
the power stone to send a shock way that
quill Drax the nebula and maybe the soul
of Gamora inside that orange stone
reduce the impact of the power stone in
order to spare her friends and always
the parts that she knows and again while
he fights Doctor Strange Stannis oozes
the soul stone to identify which of the
strange duplicates really possess the
soul Thanos also uses the reality stone
against strange in combination with the
space stone in order to pull him in and
choke him in the reality stone works the
ground beneath Strange's feet similar to
the way strange and the ancient one
would bend in fold city blocks and their
battles speaking of all this magic the
duel between Thanos and strange is
filled with interesting moves strange
casts a spell at Thanos to try to trap
him in the mirror dimension but Diana
shatters it and uses the space stone to
swirl the shards into a black hole that
sucks in all nearby matter before
strangers into butterflies according to
the concept art this wizard duel was
going to get even drippy or strange was
going to touch the houses forehead to
put him in a trance similar to how the
ancient one used bad touch on Stephen
strange and spun him off through various
realities strange and Thanos were then
going to battle in some interdimensional
tunnel with shards of the mirror
dimensions surrounding them supposedly
strange a strategy was to use the
mysteries of the multiverse to
overstimulates historian Thanos remember
that us now equals strange and magical
ability and the concept art also showed
a nose knocking astral projections of
each of these Avengers out of their
bodies apparently deep powering them
because they're not an armor this battle
ends by Thanos taking everyone out and
strange surrenders the time stone
strange summons it from out of thin air
and it glows as it floats over to Thanos
usually the stones only glow if they are
in the process of being used suggesting
that strange could be secretly rigging
the time stone with the spell perhaps
using it to establish a time loop
setting in and out points or maybe he
has projected the stone into the future
so that some future Avengers could use
it to meddle with timelines and he's
summoned it back into the present
here I can hear the voices of those of
you in the future of the real world who
have already seen in game watching this
video and being like and now on earth
and Wakanda the battle begins with cap
and Natasha and Black Panther facing the
black order with sitala promising Thanos
would have nothing but dust and not
ironically dust and blood of billions is
exactly what they a knows once there are
a lot of fun details since battle go
check out my other breakdowns for all
that stuff but right now it's
interesting to rewatch Shuri in the
sequence you could see her disconnecting
a few of visions neuron stems suggesting
that perhaps enough of his consciousness
was downloaded to her server before he
died maybe an admissions battle with
Corvus glaive he actually ends up saving
cap by impaling Corvis with his own
blade repeating the exact same move that
Corvis used on him way back in the first
act in scotland Bruce Banner also uses a
callback to Act one to defeat Cole
Obsidian banner was there the moment
Wong's portal closing chopped off Cole's
hand banner played hacky sack with it so
banner knows that Cole's new prosthetic
hand is still new awkward on him
probably clumsy enough so that when
banished shoves the Hulkbuster gauntlet
on it Cole won't be able to control it
before he goes boom Thor arrives mid
battle using the Bifrost suggesting that
store breaker is now a ridiculously
powerful object yes this is an Arthurian
hero moment for Thor and seeing this
definitely makes me want to spike a
diner mug but something about it just
feels a little easy for Thor yeah kind
of like Darth Vader and grand moff
tarkin gaining the superpower of the
Death Star or Belloc and nerdy Nazi
getting the Ark of the Covenant Raiders
or Voldemort getting the Elder Wand like
all these villains Thor for this thought
experiment gets a soul reward for
something that's more of a group effort
for a group effort yes he did have to
overcook himself in the universe's worst
tanning bed but you know what he came
out of it unscarred compare that to the
costs Thanos had to pay that dude had to
spend years building multiple armies
conquering several planets defeating
powerful Asgardians and the Avengers and
the guardians of the galaxy
breaking his own heart to sacrifice the
daughter he loves and literally having
his heart broken when Stormbreaker
watches inside of it all of it leaves
them pretty severely
in those final shots so his snap happens
in this intimate moment between Thanos
and Thor their kissing distance and the
fact that it's Thanos to a successful
not Thor makes this all thanassis movie
according to the directors but actually
this moment was originally conceived to
be more crowded concept art showed the
earth Avengers dogpiling on Thanos the
same way that the other group did on
Titan but seeing it off from just Thor's
eyes alone makes this loss even more
shocking in the way a bit satisfying he
screams like a guy on the Death Star
we've seen a proton torpedo go down the
reactors tab where nerdy Nazis face
melting off after the staff Thanos
briefly reunites with Gamora inside the
soul stone walking on this body of water
the VFX artist actually revealed that
one idea was for this water to be an
ocean of the blood of Thanos's victims
but instead the artist decided the most
shocking visual would be monochromatic
dust and ash as half the universe's
population fades each victims final
moments reflects their emotional state
Bucky's last word is Steve before the
soldier collapses 1de are ready feeling
dead inside for losing vision throws her
head back in a release welcoming death
and with Groot according to James Gunn
his final and great directed that Rocket
translates to dad and on Titan peter
parker's dustin it's more drawn-out
because his spidey sense of words and
that death was eminent and it makes him
not feel so good the movie ends with all
of the main characters cap Stark
even Thanos all knocked on their butts
it doesn't really feel like a victory
for anybody more like a double knockout
and the irony for cap is as rock bottom
as things appear to be for him in this
moment and game appears to make the
situation even worse for cap now again
this rewatch just covered the news stuff
so for other details that we caught in
our first pass during my big Easter egg
breakdown from last year the
post-credits scene breakdown really any
of the multitude of Avengers theories
tweak downs it's been a fun year comment
down below with the new thing that you
learned from rewatched and infinity war
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA boss and if you live in Los
Angeles check out my live comedy show
darkest timeline comedy on May 3rd and
every first Friday of the month
thereafter the last show sold out so you
gotta get your tickets early
thank you for watching and if any of you
jerks send me spoilers and leeks for
endgame you know what's coming yeah yeah
I just want to please
[Music]